[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos sobre la situación de los
menores de edad que están en los
refugios en la frontera de méxico con
estados unidos y este drama migratorio
que sigue creciendo nos acompaña la
licenciada teresita de guadalupe fuentes
vélez ella es directora general de
desarrollo integral de la familia del
estado de chihuahua en méxico entonces
por acompañarnos aquí en 324 y cuéntenos
usted ha hecho constantes visitas a
albergues fronterizos sobre todo los que
están entre ciudad juárez y texas qué
condiciones están los menores y los
albergues también que qué opciones
ofrecen para ellos
bueno primero buenos días gracias por su
interés en este asunto efectivamente
nuestro albergue que se encuentra en
ciudad juárez es un albergue operado por
el gobierno del estado en el que
recibimos menores no acompañados
pequeños hasta los 18 años que han
recorrido estos países desde
centroamérica hasta la frontera y que
buscan llegar a los estados unidos para
encontrarse con sus familiares es su
principal objetivo el poder llegar y
reunirse con sus familias bueno también
cuéntanos cuáles son las principales
dificultades de los albergues que usted
ha visitado qué es lo que más hace falta
y más teniendo en cuenta que estamos en
medio de una pandemia por kobe 19 así es
lo principal que hace falta desde luego
bueno pues es hacer las pruebas llegando
los niños a la frontera lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es es una prueba ellos
son puestos a disposición
de nosotros por parte del instituto
nacional de inmigración y lo primero que
hacemos cuando llegan a nuestro albergue
es proporcionarles sus necesidades
básicas verdad que puedan descansar que
puedan dormir que puedan alimentarse y
que puedan hacer una llamada a sus a sus
domicilios a sus países diciendo que
pues están ahí que no han podido cruzar
y posteriormente efectivamente tenemos
que aplicar una prueba para saber si
están en condiciones de poder estar en
convivencia con el resto de los niños
que tenemos en los diferentes albergues
este albergue es uno de los más grandes
pero tenemos otros más que han estado
apoyando recibiendo un número menor de
niños precisamente por la situación
difícil que enfrentamos en la frontera
bueno pero también cuéntenos qué
opciones tienen los menores de edad que
están en esos albergues y que llegan
solos de reencontrarse con sus familias
qué acciones legales existen para
generar estos reencuentros si
ciertamente esa es la razón principal
por la que ellos recorren todo el país
hasta llegar a la frontera en este caso
de la frontera de chihuahua que es
frontera con el estado de texas en eeuu
y lo que ellos más quieren obviamente
pues es reunirse con ese familiar con
esa mamá con ese papá con ese hermano o
hermana que tienen en eeuu ellos tienen
tres opciones la primera opción y la que
más obviamente les interesa es la de
poder cruzar sin embargo pues es la más
difícil porque pues no tienen el
documento legal que les permita ingresar
se han estado haciendo esfuerzos y
conversaciones entre ambos países
méxico eeuu en los consulados de estos
países para poder encontrar una ruta que
les permita cruzar con seguridad pero
esto está apenas trabajando es la
segunda opción que obviamente ninguno
quiere pero es una opción es la de ser
retornados a sus países de origen y la
tercera opción es proporcionarles una
visa
pues de asilo en la frontera que les
permita estar por un tiempo con la como
si fueran ciudadanos mexicanos con pueda
para poder pues trabajar estudiar pero
pues también es algo que no no no es lo
que ellos quieren puesto que pues no
conocen la ciudad no tienen manera de
conseguir un trabajo o estudiar y no es
para lo que ellos estuviese están en la
frontera claro pero esas opciones sí
claro bueno agradecemos muchísimo la
información que nos ha brindado el
tiempo es corto aquí en france 24 pero
estamos con teresita de guadalupe
fuentes vélez directora general de
desarrollo integral de familia el estado
de chihuahua en méxico que nos habla
entonces de la crisis de los menores de
edad en la frontera sur de eeuu gracias
por estar con nosotros teresita y
también gracias a ustedes por estar en
tras 24 nos vemos más adelante
[Música]